قال اللواء صلاح بابكر عمر رئيس غرفه
عمليات الاجلاء في بورتسودان قال ان هناك
لجنى تعمل على مدار الساعه لحمايه
الجاليات والبعثات الدبلوماسيه ولمتابعه
اجراءات عمليات الاجلاء عبر ميناء ومطالب
واضاف في نشره سابقه للجزيره ان كل
الاجراءات استثنائيه وان العمليات تسير
بشكل جيد حسب قوله
تم تشكيل لجان وخلايا للمتابعه بالتحركات
الجاليات والبعثات الدبلوماسيه من الخرطوم
وصول الى بورسودان وترتيب
مواقعهم هنا وتسهيل اجراءات
السفن
لتقلهم يعني كل الاجراءات كانت اجراءات
استثنائيه
اجراءات الجوازات اجراءات الجمارك كلها في
مكان تواجد هذه البعثات والجاليات
الحمد لله تصير بصوره طيبه بدات عمليات
الاخلاء يوم
21/4 وما زالت مستمره يعني على مدار
الساعه ليل نهار وعندنا
من القوات المسلحه ضباط والضباط صف على
مدار الساعه يتابعون
[موسيقى]
هذه العمليات